cette vidéo est sponsorisé par
cleanmymac plus d'informations en fin de
vidéo
je suis lyon ascendant scorpion et mon
signe lunaire c'est sagittaire je vous
le dis parce que vous êtes peut-être
envie de savoir
il ya plein de gens qui ont envie
d'avoir ce genre de trucs il ya quelques
temps je me suis inscrit sur les
applications de rencontres rester
tranquille calme et vous calmez vous
enfin et j'ai été hyper surpris par
l'importance de l'astrologie pour
beaucoup de meuf je parle des meufs
parce que c'est les profils que je vois
c'est important après c'est vrai que
dans tous les cas les meufs y croit un
peu plus que les hommes
pas de beaucoup plus il ya une étude qui
a été faite par galopent en 2005
qui dit qu'ils avaient quand même 28 %
de meuf qui croyait contre 23% de mecs
et au final astrologie je me suis dit
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ce que je vous
propose dans cette vidéo c'est de faire
le même travail que j'ai fait avec le
vaccin
c'est à dire que sans a priori on va se
poser la question de s que l'astrologie
ça existe on va repartir de la base de
ce que c'est on va essayer d'avoir le
moindre jugement possible déjà faut
comprendre le concept de l'astrologie
le concept c'est que la position des
planètes à ma naissance
un impact sur le déroulé de ma vie ma
vie amoureuse ma vie professionnelle ma
santé et c'est donc là y'a deux concepts
d'un coup il ya un concept philosophique
est un concept scientifique
le concept philosophique c'est le
concept du destin une personne qui croit
en l'astrologie
elle croit au destin en tout cas d'une
certaine manière puisque les positions
des planètes au moment de la naissance
vont déterminer ce que je suis toute ma
vie c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il ya un
horoscope
alors lorsque c'est quoi si je prends la
définition du robert c'est l'étude de la
destinée de quelqu'un effectué d'après
les données odiah call et astrologique
que fournissent sadate son honneur et
son lieu de naissance
donc dans les horoscopes du jour on est
capable de dire voilà aujourd'hui dans
votre destinée il se passa donc
quelqu'un qui croit à l'astrologie et
qui croient pas au destin
ça n'a aucun sens ça va aussi mais en
fait c'est comme si genre vous aimiez le
thé mais vous pouviez pas boire d'eau ça
marche pas ça colle passé 11 non je dis
pas que le dessin n'existe pas mais ce
que je dis ce que si quelqu'un vous dit
qu'il ne croit pas au destin mais qui
croit en l'astrologie
ça n'a pas de sens le deuxième concept
les scientifiques c'est dire que les
planètes
elle exerce une force assez puissante
sur nous pour avoir un impact sur nos
vies pourquoi pas pourquoi pas alors les
forces que les planètes
elle exerce y en a pas masse j'ai pas
fait exprès mais c'est une blague
scientifiques sur la masse avec la
gravitation
ces forces là il y en a pas tant que ça
il ya la force électromagnétique donc
c'est au tour de la planète et il y à la
gravitation
alors cette force on a une formule 1 on
a une formule pour la calculer et bah si
on fait des calculs on se rend compte
que par exemple la force qu'exerce mars
sur nous et humain c'est le même ordre
de grandeur que celle d'un pote à un
mètre de boue dans la définition même du
truc c'est compliqué genre comment des
planètes peuvent avoir un impact sur moi
a priori la réponse qu'elles peuvent pas
avoir un impact sur man ou alors si un
pacte et l'ida il est infime par rapport
à l'impact de plein d'autres choses qui
sont autour de moi et qui du coup
écraserait cet impact
après voilà peut-être qu'on n'est pas
assez avancée en astrophysique et qu' il
ya des fortes mais on l'est on les
connaît pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas du
coup faudrait des études faut des études
où on prend un grand panel de gens et on
regarde si leur signe astrologique
change quelque chose quoi j'ai pas honte
mais c'est trouver quelque chose
ses études elle existe c'est des études
statistiques mais il ya un problème
majeur dans ces études statistiques
c'est que on sait pas ce qu'on cherche
et donc du coup on cherche en fait une
caractéristique qui aurait un écart
statistiques significatif en fonction
des signes astrologiques
mais c'est très vague et quand même une
caractéristique et ça ça pose un
problème je vous parlais de deux d'entre
elles
d'abord en 1997 on à saxe qui sort une
monographie c'est-à-dire un traité sous
la forme d'un livre qui s'appelle die
acte astrologie donc le dossier
astrologie vraiment j'ai pas fait du
tout allemand donc peut-être que mon
accent est horrible et j'en suis désolé
d'ailleurs c'est pas n'importe quel sac
ce c'est guenter sexe
wingen taxe héritiers homme d'affaires
multimillionnaire photographe et
sportifs de haut niveau mais surtout et
c'est rare que ce soit dans ce sens-là
ex mari de brigitte parking bardot
gunter sachs ou plutôt devrais je dire
guenther sexe considéré comme un playboy
dans les années 60 président de nombreux
clubs fermés dont le dracula club dont
il sait aussi suicidé pour échapper à
l'oeil mais même dans cette thèse saxe
va prendre tout un tas de statistiques
il va prendre différents types de crimes
donc j'ai pas par exemple les meurtres
les vols etc et il va lier ça aux signes
astrologiques
le but étant de prouver un lien de
causalité malheureusement qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est qu'il sort son étude et
genre vraiment l'année d'après il est
des bunkers de trois côtés différents
que ce sera à vous mêler des bonnes
qu'agent description il est de nouveau
débuté en 2003 ou en gros on montre que
en fait ces statistiques là si on les
analyse de plein d'autres façons
différentes
il n'y a pas de lien de causalité a
lancé vous analyse avec une méthode dite
de tout analyser ça donne le tableau
suivant et vous voyez que plus la case
est foncée plus on a recensé de cas et
tant qu est ce qui se dégage renvoie ce
tableau maïs dégage des colonnes et donc
c'est des colonnes en fonction du type
de crime et non des lignes en fonction
du signe astrologique et à une seule
colonne un petit peu chelou c'est la
colonne des vols et même l'agent par
exemple les sagittaire qui ont fait le
moins de vols et ben le chiffre de
sagittaire qui ont fait des vols et bien
correspond quand même à la fourchette
statistiques attendues père ça me fait
rire parce que les auteurs qui ont signé
cette étude
ils ont mis leur nom mais aussi leur
signe astrologique dans la petit clin
d'oeil se marrant c'est marrant on se
marre on se marre ou pas et à une autre
étude que j'ai trop intéressante c'est
une étude qui date de 2007 foi qui nous
vient de didier castille à lui va
prendre tous les morts entre 1979 et
1997 et va comparer la date de leur mort
à la date de la renaissance c'est les
fichiers annuelle de l'état civil de
l'insee son but ça va être d'infirmer ou
d'affirmer l'hypothèse suivante il
n'existe pas de lien statistique entre
la date de décès d'une personne et sa
date de naissance avant grec loin vous
pouvez faire pause et mettre en
commentaire
ce que vous pensez être la réponse est
ce qu un lien statistique ou et tant que
vous y êtes d'ailleurs vous
par exemple laïque et cette vidéo et
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
voilà je le dis jamais c'est vrai que je
le dis jamais là on fait une petite
pause pourront pas le faire ça ou ça
vous plaît la vidéo pour l'instant moi
j'ai bien aimé l'écrire en tout cas je
trouve ça intéressant pour l'instant
alors à votre avis eh bien on ne peut
pas dire qu'il n'ya pas de lien
statistique entre la date de décès et la
date de naissance
on peut pas dire qu a pas de lien
statistique parce que voilà la courbe
nous placer un graphe de l'étude et on
voit quand même qu'il y a plus de décès
au moment des anniversaires
le problème c'est que ça prouve rien d'
astrologique et le dit lui-même
ça peut être dû à plein d'autres choses
ça peut être dû par exemple au fait que
au moment de leur anniversaire les
jambes à ils font plus cela fait donc
ils peuvent de l'alcool et ses attaques
qui comprend la route ou bien il peut y
avoir plus de suicides à cette période
là parce que c'est une date importante
dans tous les cas c'est pas une preuve
de l'influencé des astres sur nos vies
il a fait d'autres études qui montrent
par exemple que certains signes
astrologiques se marrait plus entre là
encore c'est le même problème
ça peut être simplement parce que les
gens vivent des choses similaires au
même moment et il peut y avoir plein
d'autres acteurs
donc c'est pas des preuves non plus il
ya une forme que j'ai trouvé qui je
trouve résume assez bien la chose
raisonner avec les astrologues c'est
boxé avec un oreiller de plumes on
l'enfoncé en un point
il se regonflent ailleurs pour
comprendre vraiment cette phrase vous
parle d'une dernière étude celle qui a
fait le plus de bruit c'est l'étude de
l'effet mars et je vous préviens c'est
un petit peu triste
cette étude elle a été menée par michel
gauclin avec sa première femme françoise
et il avait une hypothèse qui ont passé
beaucoup de temps à essayer de prouver
cette hypothèse c'est qu'il ya un lien
entre la destinée de certains sportifs
et la place qu'avait mars dans le ciel
au moment de leur naissance ont fait
l'étude
et on se rend compte que quand même 18 4
76% des sportifs qui avait mars au bon
endroit dans le ciel à leur naissance et
c'est plus que la fréquence de référence
le problème c'est que c'est plus mais
c'est pas beaucoup plus parce qu'à la
fréquence de référence
elle est de 18,2 donc cet écart de 0 56%
il n'est pas assez significatif est là
michel et françoise ils font quoi ils
disent ok mais en fait c'est parce que
ça ne touche que les sportifs qui ont
vraiment genre une carrière de ouf
il faut virer tous ces sportifs là et
faut virer ceux qui font ces paires fla
etc etc
et c'est le souci c'est que quand on
sait pas ce qu'on cherche on peut
toujours tenter de se retourner et c'est
pour faire dire à l'étude
ce qu'on a vraiment envie qu'elle dise
d'où le coup de laurier faisait que
c'est triste
michel gauclin s'est suicidé le 20 mai
1991 en demandant à un ami de détruire
toutes les données de ses études en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que à
ce jour scientifiquement n'y a aucune
preuve de l'impact de la position des
planètes sur nos vies et c'est peut-être
pour ça que quand je lis la description
d'un lion un ascendant scorpion
je me reconnais pas du tout par exemple
grâce à son magnétisme attractif il est
un séducteur inné qui aime s'investir à
fond dans ses relations sa vie amoureuse
est rempli de sensualité de charme de
fusion d'originalité il aime aussi la
liberté dans ses relations même si ses
passions dure longtemps et qu'il est
assez fidèle en amour il est autoritaire
dans ses relations et a du mal à se
remettre en question quand il s'agit de
sentiments j'avoue c'est totalement moi
c'est chelou ça attends je continue
fougue passionné et créatif
la sensualité fait partie intégrante de
ses relations de couple il est prouvé sa
puissance ou sexuelles pour cela il
n'hésite pas à faire passer du temps
pour satisfaire sa partenaire pendant
les préliminaires créatif il affectionne
les positions dominantes dans ces jeux
sexuels
non mais c'est fou c'est tellement moins
enfin je veux dire puissance sexuelle
c'est mon second prénom vous si ça vous
fait ça genre lire votre signe astro et
genre se reconnaître totalement dedans
et bien c'est normal c'est un biais
cognitif c'est notre cerveau qui ne vous
des tours et ça s'appelle l'effet barnum
les barnums ça a été inventé par le
psychologue john barnum pas du tout mais
pas du tout vous êtes naïf vous êtes
naïf suivait un petit peu me fait pas
confiance comme ça suivait ça a été
nommé comme ça par le psychologue paul
mills en hommage à phinéas taylor barnum
alors phinéas barnum c'est un personnage
qui est assez fou dans l'histoire du
spectacle aux états unis vous invite à
les creuser
parce que son histoire est folle et donc
ce monsieur à un moment de sa vie là une
période assez difficile où il donnait
des petits spectacles et disait des
généralités aux gens qu'ils se
reconnaissaient dans ce qu'il disait
d'où l'effet barnum mais en vrai un des
premiers qui a théorisé cet effet ce
n'est pas paul mills mais c'est bertram
foreurs d'où le fait qu'on l'appelle
aussi l'effet foreurs d'ailleurs je
trouve ça plus juste de l'appeler comme
ça foreurs à faire l'expérience suivante
et à faire un test de personnalité à ses
élèves
sauf que au lieu de leur donner le vrai
résultat du test
avec la description qui correspond il à
faire une seule description qui va
donner à tout le monde en 100 croire que
c'est le résultat du test de
personnalité et ce texte il le composent
à partir d'horoscope alors je vous mets
le texte en description mais je vous
lire le début vous avez besoin d'être
aimé et admiré et pourtant vous êtes
critique avec vous même vous avez certes
des points faibles dans votre
personnalité mais vous savez
généralement les compenser vous avez un
potentiel considérable que vous n'avez
pas encore utilisé à votre avantage
il a demandé ensuite à ses élèves de
noter la pertinence de ce texte par
rapport à leur personnalité de 0 à 5
donc zéro étant le moins pertinent et 5
étant hyper pertinent et la moyenne des
notes des élèves s'étaient 4,26 c'est un
très bon score les amendes que quasiment
tout le monde se reconnaissaient dans
cette description est en fait c'est la
même chose qui se produit quand on lit
notre horoscope notre profil astro et ça
me fait chier de le dire mais il n'y a
pas de force suprême qui a décrété que
j'étais une puissance sexuelle
donc voilà l'astrologie sur le principe
de base on n'a pas de preuves sur malgré
le fait qu'on n'ait pas de preuve
est ce que ça aurait un impact quand
même on n'a pas de preuves quand on se
rend compte que en fait ce qui fait
qu'on se reconnaît grave dans ce qu on
lit ça un biais cognitif hyper simple à
démontrer ça commence à être difficile
d'y croire mais vous savez ce qui
vraiment enterrerait le concept pour moi
ce serait par exemple qu'on se rende
compte qu'on a oublié carrément un signe
du zodiaque
quand on a établi l'astrologie et que du
coup ça décale tous et les astrologues
par exemple se battrait pour savoir s'il
faut le garder ou non ce serait fou ça
non genre un signe entre le 29 novembre
et le 18 décembre
on pourrait l'appeler par exemple le
serpentaire
il aurait été déjà découvert à l'époque
des égyptiens en fait ce qui serait
encore plus fou c'est que avoué les
émaux gilles avec les signes du zodiaque
et ben il est son signe et qu'ils soient
dans votre téléphone genre là maintenant
et que juste vous l'avez jamais remarqué
ça serait dingue genre ça pourrait
ressembler à ça ça serait fou quand même
que ce truc qui existe et 20 sa peau -
ce serait quand même une preuve
supplémentaire que tout ça c'est
peut-être un peu n'importe quoi alors
après c'est sympa parce que ça fait des
histoires ça fait des histoires et nous
on aime les histoires nous les humains
on aime se raconter des histoires et où
s'écoule c'est drôle mais il faut que ça
reste que des histoires à prendre des
décisions à cause de ses histoires
alors quand des décisions
professionnelles à cause de ses
histoires on va pas prendre des
décisions de couple à cause de ses
histoires ça ce serait vraiment dommage
ça ce serait vraiment dommage ce n'est
que des histoires
après si malgré tout ce que je vous ai
dis là vous y croyez encore vous seriez
pas un peu bélier si vous êtes un
utilisateur de mac et voulait lui donner
un petit coup de neuf
j'ai ce qu'il faut parce que le sponsor
de cette vidéo c'est cleanmymac si une
application qui va à la fois genre
nettoyer des fichiers que vous avez dans
des caches dans des trucs comme ça
qu'ils prennent de la place pour rien
voilà ça ça les repères c'est les kin il
ya un anti malware
il va aussi simplement optimiser votre
mac pour que ça ressemble plus vite il a
vidé de la rame ce genre de trucs
l'application elle est solide
ça fait 12 ans qu'elle existe vraiment
grosse ancienneté et elle est utilisée
quotidiennement par des millions
d'utilisateurs
comme vous le voyez je les utilise cette
semaine ça à nettoyer plein de dossiers
que j'avais tout qui servait à rien ça
fait ça via une fonctionnalité qui est
jean la fonctionnalité phare de
l'application qui s'appelle l'analyse
intelligente et en rossa examine votre
disque pour trouver les fichiers
journaux du système et les caches qui ne
sont plus nécessaires
et c'est aussi ce double truc que je
vous disais tout à l'heure avec
l'analyse de fichiers malveillants et
les tâches d'optimisation pour accélérer
votre mac perso il ya une autre
fonctionnalité que j'adore qui s'appelle
le télescope sur d'autres applications
et donc là ce que j'aime bien c'est que
tout est rassemblées en une seule
l'anru c'est une fonctionnalité qui
permet de voir genre visuellement tout
de suite qu est ce qui prend de la place
sur votre disque je poussais hyper
pratique de loire visuellement comme ça
ça me permet de faire un meilleur
arbitrage entre ce que je garde ce que
je stocke etc
l'application est gratuite il ya des
fonctions détection premium je voulais
un lien dans la description et je les
remercie une fois encore pour l'heure
sponsorisée
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à me suivre
sur instagram on a on a dépassé les 60
mille là haut et je voulais vous dire on
a dépassé les 600 milles sur la chaîne
youtube
voilà tout ça tout ça vous c'est trop
cool quoi bon je vous en reparlerai plus
tard c'est pas le c'est pas le moment la
love peace chao à tout le monde sauf au
verso si une de merde je rigole je
rigole c'était face il fallait que je
tape sur quelqu'un c'était facile je
vous embrasse les verso les verseaux
vous êtes les meilleurs